voilà monsieur bonjour après la séance
de la nuit dernière à l'assemblée
nationale la querelle la guerre diront
certains entre guillemets entre
partisans du laïc et du privé rebondi en
effet avant de poser la question de
confiance aux députés le ministre de
l'éducation nationale monsieur savary et
monsieur pierre mauroy le premier
ministre ont au dernier moment a demandé
une nouvelle fois le projet sur un point
qui déplaisait souverainement au député
socialiste à savoir que l'état se
substituer aux villes qui
n'accepteraient pas de subventionner les
établissements privés dépendant d'elle
et cela sans limite de temps dans le
texte initial
c'est ce dernier point qui a changé
désormais l'aide de l'état ne pourra
dépasser 9 ans et 6 9 ans après le vote
de la loi la ville ne veut toujours pas
subventionnée l'école privée municipal
et bien 5 ans et 6 50 % au moins du
personnel enseignant n'a pas choisi
d'être titularisé comme fonctionnaire et
bien l'établissement privé devra alors
se débrouiller seul pour assurer son
fonctionnement
alors avant de revenir sur le débat d'un
nuit dernière
voyons tout de suite l'érection ce matin
du côté des tenants de l'enseignement
privé qui organise une journée de
manifestations à travers la france
baptisé alerte
le reportage de serre je me serais
ils sont là au pied de la tour près de
la gare montparnasse qui pourrait-on
dire le débouché tout naturel de la
bretagne
ce soir ils vont aller faire un tour à
l'église de la trinité à paris
un avant goût pour une plus grande manif
pour l'instant ils se chauffent au
soleil en commentant l'amendement au
projet savary qui c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire ne les transporte pas de
joie et attendez on savait très bien que
le parti socialiste aurait eu des
concessions peut t'aider c'était assez
évident mais c'est le piège
supplémentaires en fait par rapport au
projet de charles est agréable pour nous
dont vous cette chorale et politique en
cassation n'est pas politique qu'elle
soit c'est une querelle d'abord de
volonté de gens à vouloir à un
enseignement tels que je décide et nous
ne voulons déclaré la guerre à personne
nous voulons simplement garder notre
dignité et notre responsabilité de
perdre trois buts oui c'était tout à
fait polémique
si apple où on a paré pour les options
politiques mais telle politique nous
oui je crois qu'il faut se référer au
parlement prend beaucoup j'en étais pas
soit imprégné peut-être de ceux de ce
projet qui en fait une mainmise m'ont
pas sur eux simplement les gens mais sur
les idées autant de la mairie nous
chantions au revoir ce revenu
c'est mon petit sans vous pensé de la
banque est à mon avis c'est une raison
de plus pour manifester pour les